Let's talk about data modeling.
All right.
So um
we have started to explore this in the
conversations we've already had this
morning. Um which is
uh
there is no data model
within Neo4j until you create data in
it.
Yeah.
You don't have to create
a define a table structure
before you put a thing in it.
Yeah. You don't have to create a
structure of what a node looks like or a
structure of what a relationship looks
like before you create them. There is no
data model until you create the data in
the graph. Right?
So um
the the the term is schema-optional.
Yeah.
Um
you can create
any data
with any labels, with any properties,
with any relationships that you want.
And unless you constrain it,
you can do whatever.
Right?
Um
constraints are really useful,
particularly for things like IDs. So,
you know, if there is a node with the
label customer, it must have a customer
ID property, and that customer ID
property must be unique.
So, you can create constraints, but by
default,
anything goes. Right? And that's one of
the reasons we use graphs because it's a
highly flexible structure that allows us
to model particularly real-world things.
Right?
So,
might make us feel a little bit
uncomfortable,
but that's why we use them.
Right? [laughter]
Yeah. So, constraints are good, yeah,
but we use them where we need to use
them. Yeah.
Um okay. So, I want to talk about this
idea of like gold the golden rule. So,
the golden rule of graph data modeling
is noun verb noun.
Customer
uh lives at address.
Yeah, noun verb noun. Person acted in
movie.